India has a trash problem it's
everywhere people throw it on streets in
the rivers on empty land anywhere except
for outside their own homes people they
will make a nuisance they had public
places they will throw garbage at night
time or any time and it is very
difficult that - where's the throne this
garbage
more than 127 thousand tons of solid
waste is generated every day in India
garbage trucks pick up the bulk of it
but much is simply dumped in public
spaces to counter this chronic problem
many of India's cities are turning to
their own citizens asking them to play
whistleblowers using a technology more
commonly known for teenage chatter our
civil number 7 by 24 modulus - yeah for
America at Margaritaville is me at
aquarium the world level Jeff hello mr.
Lovato de filippi sir Anita crevice over
the phone number as I watch the part of
the - Navi Mumbai is a satellite city to
the north east of Mumbai and it's in
desperate to avoid the fate of its
folder filthier neighbor the whatsapp
helplines
feed tips to roving patrols known as
garbage nuisance squads yeah Miami Nagar
Palika Chacarita dramedy sorry chicken
is on the table
Sarita Connie petrol kerosene when jet
kinetically karateka the same a second
leaders not Alan Archer there are beaten
up by leverage Samburu pay dirt at tikka
need to stress cured to statically
taught model wedlock the raddest airway
i say then that Makarov a denture Coto
tips are pouring in and the officers say
it's already making a difference not we
do more subtly a lil a
the episode on Regan she was overly
complicated camera Amala coupe soap
opera day he's on a debate on the sport
zone Amita Sehgal
kar-wai guruship po team spoke quickly
cleaning up litter and debris as well as
fining violators the program's
efficiency has already made it popular
for the city residents even those being
fined think it's a good idea
pankot there to dis of them data botany
the challenge is not to over rely on the
simpler words too much snitching can
lead to conflicts between residents and
we are taking the initiative for this
advanced technologies to improve our
services and to keep city clean and
Hindi city whistle blowing is a
quick-fire way to curb the problem but
ultimately city officials will need to
change the culture of dumping in order
to solve india's trash problem